if you suffered from racial inequality
if you suffered from gender inequality
you would be completely justified in the
fact that you are not achieving the
things that other people who didn't have
those disadvantages have achieved and I
say this as a white guy who was born in
America to a doctor father but at the
same degree you have the opportunity
that Chris nor I have which is that you
can be an inspiration to people who went
through the same thing because I can
promise that there is somebody who has
had it worse and has done it better
Alex o'muzzy welcome to the show thank
you for having me my pleasure man uh one
of my favorite things to do is to scrape
through people's twitters that uh
aphorists and come up with little pithy
statements and then break them down so I
want to go through some of the things
that I've learned from you over the last
year or so go into those and then
there's some talking points I don't
think I've heard you speak about before
as well I want to get
amped beautiful so the first one is so
many lives would transform overnight if
they realized my life sucks I have
nothing going for me really means I have
nothing to lose and that makes you a
very dangerous person
so
in any kind of game position so like in
business right
every position has advantages and
disadvantages and a lot of people look
at the really big guys and they're like
man they uh they like they're like
they're looking at me like must be easy
for Alex right and I remember when we
had uh Jim launch and we had a very big
company I would tell the guys who were
coming I was like if you're trying to
compete against me I was like you have
advantages I was like if you're on a
sales call you're like listen you're
just a number to Alex you're never gonna
talk to Alex right here with me you're
gonna get my attention I'm the one right
I was like that's how you're gonna throw
stones at me I was like but on the flip
side if it's me marketing to the masses
I'm gonna be like this kid's in his
mom's basement he has no idea what he's
doing he's been in business for 12
months and of course he has no idea like
wouldn't you want somebody who's
thousands of success stories behind it
because we've made a system like both
sides have advantages and so what
happens is people are in this small
position where they're more Nimble they
can give more personalized attention to
people Etc
and they see it as a pure disadvantage
and so you can flip the fact that you
have nothing going for you with you have
nothing to lose and that means that you
can take lots of risks very quickly and
end up in the exact same position you
are which is nothing and so if you
eliminate downside it should decrease
your action threshold meaning you should
be able to do more things faster rather
than do fewer things because you don't
have a great life or things going for
you and so I think if people flip that
a lot more people would take action
because they actually realized the
advantage of their position Jack butcher
says you get rich by taking lots of risk
with small amounts of money and you stay
Rich by taking small amounts of risk
with lots of money yes I wholeheartedly
agree I didn't know that was his quote
uh he may have repurposed it there's
something called churchillion Drift do
you know what that is no so it's a a
phenomenon at the core it's not the
opposite it's that um quotes that
weren't said by Churchill often get like
erroneously attributed to him it's like
all quotes lead back to Churchill even
though they didn't and Socrates yeah
it's like it's just one of those things
where it's like I I think Churchill once
said yeah get rich by making large
amounts it's like no he [__] but
there's another one as well uh that a
good friend James Smith talked about
which is if you're succeeding at a job
that you hate imagine how good you'd be
at a job that you loved and that's kind
of the same this person is starting from
essentially zero how much [__] worse
can it get right
is the downside if you can eliminate
someone's downside for action it's like
then
the bias it should bias you towards
taking action why is it that
people in that case if they do have
nothing to lose still feel like they
have lots to lose because I think most
of the times so this I think this is
really important is that
they have nothing objectively to lose
and so everything that they feel like
they have to lose is purely made up in
their mind it's stories that tell
themselves about what other people are
going to think about them when those
people aren't even think about them to
begin with right but like that's where
they live all of their lives or live out
all of the potential downside is in the
mere reflection of what other people
will think about them in the future
should they fail
and I think that is the like if we were
if we're trying to get real and I'm like
talking to somebody's like well I I mean
because I know that if I actually had
somebody in front of me they'd start
squirming right if I said the first
thing right like you have nothing to
lose and then because then they do have
something to lose and I just have to
name it for them and be like okay who's
the person in your mind who's the voice
it's like blah blah six questions deep
it's my uncle okay why like let me state
it this way will
your belief that you're going to be
viewed as a failure by your uncle be the
sole reason that you live the rest of
your life below your potential and
regret everything that you don't do
because of Uncle Tom
that's the wrong one Uncle Harry
when you say it like that all of a
sudden they're like I don't want to let
Uncle Harry have that kind of power and
then all of a sudden it breaks and then
they like get free of it and so I think
it's getting really specific and really
narrow on the because people say it's
Society it's other people it's like it's
usually one or two voices and if you can
get really specific on whose voice it is
then you can name it and then like I
think I'm a big believer in like shame
only exists in the shadows which is like
once you put it in the light you look at
it and you're like
my mom that was really it like when I
really think about it it's because it's
not even just my mom it's my mom in this
circumstance when I come back home for
Thanksgiving I just am so afraid of the
comment that she's gonna make it's like
well what if we confront that okay your
mom you sit down at Thanksgiving dinner
and you haven't made money yet and you
quit your job now what
is that better than you spending the
next 60 years hating her or resenting
her for the fact that she held you back
and then it's like when you give the
real scenario they're like well [__] and
then like this weight comes off and
they're like [__] I guess I should do
this and you're like yeah shame on me
Shadows is nice yeah I like that and it
definitely is cleansing to just be like
look here it is out in front of you yeah
and it really you realize just how
irrational it is because we don't want
to look at it yeah because it's in the
shadow and we put in the shadows because
of how it makes us feel about ourselves
in my opinion and so it's it's so scary
we avoid it we avoid it we avoid avoid
it but it's like I think the faster you
can kind of build that muscle of like
huh I've got this hesitation what is the
real reason because like logically I can
do that whole thing cool you have
nothing to lose you're poor great zero
right okay but then what is it that I'm
that I do have something to lose it's
relational Capital it's status within my
tiny micro community that doesn't matter
but like my perceived status okay name
the names and but by pulling it out from
the Shadows
it'll but like that confrontation from
here to here is I think where all the
fear is
because it's embarrassing
to be like it's my mom the other perfect
thing or great realization I think for
anybody that's starting out and is
feeling self-conscious about what other
people are going to think is when you're
starting out by Design there are so few
people looking at you that even if you
do fail no one [__] sees right so
this is something we realized when we
were running nightclubs that we would
try and launch a new event around
freshers week in September and we would
we would have this great idea and it
would be everything would be about
flamingos or everything would be it
would be a smart night on a Tuesday so
people could go out after they've been
to sports club or whatever it was
and then it would flop right and we'd do
150 people and all of the guys that work
for us would be stood outside looking
destitute and upset and they're good so
unbearables there so it looks like
there's more room oh dude we had so many
tricks we'd pump the pump the room full
of smoke we would pad the back off so
that everyone had to go to the front we
get the DJ to play music all sorts of
[__] but all of the boys would be like
[__] this makes us look so bad
everyone's gonna think that we're [__] I
was like no no no no 150 people are
gonna think that we're [__] yeah like
the advantage of running a [__] business
that doesn't reach many people is that
not many people saw your [__] business
yeah and that's when you're starting out
people that are concerned about becoming
a content creator I I'm worried about
starting a podcast because what if
everyone sees how [__] my podcast is
it's like dude no one's going to see a
[__] podcast it took me three years
three and a half years to get even an
appreciable amount of people listening
to this show and it was effort three
times a week no one cares when you start
so you can be liberated from that as
well and it's just objection handling
objection handling objection handling
all the way down I think a lot I think a
couple frames that are just different
frames around content making since we're
on the topic
um that helped me was one is seeing it
as practice rather than the game
so like when we're doing a podcast if
you start you're like hey I'm gonna do a
podcast I'm gonna post it's practice for
me getting better for future me rather
than like I'm like this is the main game
it's like no the game is the whole thing
and this is just like we're still in
pre-season like these these these scores
these touchdowns don't even matter yet
right now you can say yet even though
like I can still feel like I'm a
preseason but I think from a mental
framework it actually decreases the
stakes associated with doing it and I
think that's been helpful for me
especially it was in the earlier days
the other one was um kind of the equal
opposite of this problem which is not
wanting to start because no one's
watching because it feels like you're
doing all this work what's the point and
so I actually the little mental trick
that I had was um one I track lots of
stuff and the more ways you track the
more ways you can win and so it's a
little thing that I found out so like if
you track 100 stats and you only need
one of them to go up so you feel like
you made some progress so that's like an
easy one and the second thing around the
tracking is that I would look at like
the biggest possible number so a lot of
times you can see like the impressions
of you know a post that you make even if
you only got like 16 likes I got like
100 Impressions and I thought to myself
I was like well if there was a room of
100 people I'd be stoked like that would
be awesome especially in the early days
I was like that would be I would totally
feel like that was worthwhile and so
taking those little impression numbers
and pretending that they were like micro
events that I was making the work or the
content for all of a sudden made it feel
worth it for me and so the combination
of I can have a small room and I'm
really impacting like when I get a view
that has like 13 views on it you know
for like a video in the early days I'd
be like well shoot I made this video and
13 people saw I was like a small room
like that works but
looking at both absolute growth and
relative growth so it's like okay well I
went from 10 followers this month to 15
followers this month it's like well you
can say that you only gain five
followers I was like or you can say that
you gained by you went up by 50 and that
was exciting and so then I because I'm a
Excel projection guy I was like okay
well if I do this every month and the
team knows this because I project
everything out I'm like if we do this
because I I'll predict where we're going
to be in like 12 months and how about
usually hit it very really very but how
do you account for the unforeseen
5 million play
video that comes in well that's my
padding right so like I'll project that
with no white swan events where
something good happens yeah but it just
if we keep doing what we're currently
doing at this trajectory we compound at
13 a month yeah that's what it is right
now so 13 monthly and that's just on one
of the platforms we're on
um and so I can just see what we're
going to be at six months and that's
exciting so James Smith gamifies it in
the same way you're busy yeah absolutely
exactly the same way and he always says
that it's just like playing uh levels on
a computer game in this month wow like I
got another XP point or whatever and I
think that's very important because
social media and the fact that it is
associated with status even though
everybody says oh you know it doesn't
really matter and blah blah it does like
it's very hard for us to remove the
human hierarchy from what is evidently
just Quantified [__] status right on
a screen and what he did was he removed
himself a lot existentially from that by
saying it's not comment on my worth as a
person it's not a comment on whether I'm
you know going to be loved or accepted
by the world
it's me putting some stuff out and wow
we won this month yeah and this month oh
maybe we didn't win why didn't we win
where I go back the same way as if
someone beats you at FIFA unless you
like a pro FIFA Player or whatever but
again with that what's the difference
between the the amateur FIFA Player and
the pro FIFA Player the pro has put his
existential connection right to his
content and the success of it oh my God
so many little things on this that I
want to go into one of them is uh so Dr
cash is my closest friend he's like a
behavioral whatever loves studying why
humans do things
um and so people who are most successful
a lot of times with their it's not that
they necessarily have more willpower
they find ways to they find other ways
to reward themselves
and so he's like the more skills you
have the more ways you have to reward
yourself and so somebody who somebody
can extend how long their time Horizon
is because they do gamify it so people
who don't have the skills of figuring
out ways to reward themselves in the
meantime can't make it the whole way but
that's like when you're doing cardio and
you're like okay it's 5 30 you know it's
five times five to get out of here right
you you create micro games within the
longer game to keep yourself going and
the thing is I've seen that across uh
verticals so like if you look at uh so
Travis mesh is a Olympic lifter Olympic
lifting coach out of North Carolina and
he has this really cool way of getting
lifters to PR every workout so have a
personal record every workout and what
he does is he have them map every single
set in rep range for every single lift
at every weight and so what happens is
all you have to do is go through your
book of 200 lifts and every single
weight and you can always find one that
you did a year ago and I'm like this is
my eight rep max PB on good mornings yes
and you're like well I can hit nine on
this or I can add five pounds to it and
so every workout they win yeah and so
they get excited because they get
rewarded every workout and so that's why
it's like the more ways you track the
more ways you can win and then I think
that that's those little micro wins can
keep you going over the long game that
you have to just keep playing one of the
other Associated tweets that you did was
if your life sucks the easiest thing is
to change your environment oh yeah this
is something that I saw moving from a
very good life in the UK to now I as
excellent of a life as I can imagine in
Austin and I'd met about a million
people throughout my time as a club
promoter and had a handful of friends I
was like [__] like I feel like my people
met to friend conversion should be
higher than this I feel like I'm the the
funnel is very wide and like the
conversions are very low to use your
terminology yeah and then moved out to
Austin and it's like I have more friends
than people I've met which is just
[__] insane so
definitely changing your environment
what other ways given that not everybody
could move to Austin what other ways
would you say if your life sucks the
easiest thing is to change your
environment what other ways could
someone do that I mean the environment
is
I mean like you know this is a I'm going
to tangent I'm gonna come back so if
you've ever heard somebody say like man
I hate Cincinnati Cincinnati sucks right
or they go some City and like they go
there for two days and they make a
judgment across the entire city right
but it's like okay let's go really deep
you ate at three restaurants and you saw
seven total people in Cincinnati does
Cincinnati suck or do the two
restaurants that you went to or the
seven people that you were with not are
they not that cool well it's so easy to
just move like two miles down the street
it's the same reason people do
staycations it's like you don't even
need to change cities you can be in the
same city and still change the
environment like just moving out of your
mom's basement you know what I mean and
just going into another place with four
guys can change the environment and so
like that's the the thing that to me was
so telling on this was uh so heroin
addiction
super addicting I'll put it that way and
when a bunch of soldiers came back from
Vietnam they had been addicted I don't
know if you've heard of this right 25
percent of soldiers who went to Vietnam
tried heroin it was like an insane
statistic and in the U.S 90 of heroin
addicts who go to clinics relapse so
they have a 10 long-term success rate
tough
the stats are completely reversed from
people who got addicted or did heroin in
Vietnam and then came back to the US
which then you could make the you could
draw the line which is
it's better to change your environment
than to even do anything else because
what happens is you eliminate all the
triggers and cues that are associated
with The Habit that you're trying to
destroy do you see that the American
government was absolutely concerned that
there was going to be an epidemic yeah
they were they were adamant that all of
these soldiers were going to come home
and they were going to be these veterans
that were all addicted to heroin yeah
wild and there are for sure but
proportion so much proportion less than
their quote should be because the
problem with the current system of and
like for anyone who's listening you can
still extrapolate the principle or the
concept people are in the environment
that they are addicted they change
environments and they go to a clinic
they change the environment they change
their behavior and then they go back to
the same environment and their behavior
changes yet again to match the
environment and so it's like if you want
to change your actions the easiest thing
you can do is just change the
environment because if you can do that a
lot of times a lot of the negative
things you have you just don't get
triggered you don't get the cue for the
behavior it just gets extinguished so
the way that I've worked this into my
home working setup is I think I have six
or seven different places that I can
work at and I do different tasks at each
one of them so I've got a place I'm
writing a book I've got a place that I
write my book that's first thing in the
morning I've got a place that I do my
emails at that's a recumbent desk bike
which is
[__] unbelievable dude zone two cut
180 minutes a week of zone two cardio
180 minutes a week of emails with Zone 2
cardio uh the place outside I've got my
studio record inside we've got two
living rooms with different houses that
I can go into I'm like different spots
for each one and if I'm in this Vibe I'm
over here and everything's a bit go for
a walk come back move somewhere else now
I'm in a different mode totally and I
I'm actually so it works in the equal
opposite too if you want to start
something right so like we were talking
about was extinguishing bad habits by
changing the environment by eliminating
the queue but on the flip side
if you want to start a habit like for me
one of my quote famous ones is like I
want to put sunscreen on it's like this
it's like one habit that's like 80 20.
why do you need to put sunscreen on so
much because oh no not so much if I
could just if you do like it's like kind
of like walking like if you just walk
once a day and if like if everyone just
did that like you add 10 years to
everyone's like it's like what are the
few things it's like baby aspirin walk
like if you do that crushing it uh from
a like uh skin cancer prevention a and
then B just like less wrinkled Alex
future
um
suntan lotion or SPF stuff uh is like
the the 80 20 of that right instead of
having a zillion other things so like
okay I don't like it I realize the
reason I don't like it I don't like oil
on my hands
sounds so stupid but like that's enough
punishment for me doing it that I
stopped doing it and so I had to
overcome two things one was that I hate
the oil on my hands and the second is
that I don't remember so I put
one thing of sunscreen at each of my
watering holes so I get cued because I
see it as soon as I sit down so I eat
lunch at the same table I work at the
same table and on my nightstand there's
the three places that I spend my time
and so I have one in each of the three
places and then the type of sunscreen I
have is that I have one that's dispensed
through a thing so I don't actually have
to touch it
so it's like do I know what it's like if
you can identify why you don't like
doing something then you can isolate why
am I being punished for this behavior
and think okay is there a way I can fix
it and the other is how can I cue myself
on a more regular basis by changing my
environment rather than setting an alarm
on my phone where if it goes off right
now in the little podcast I'm not going
to pull out suntan lotion or I'd have to
carry everything with me which I would
never do right that would punish me far
more than just not putting it on to
begin with and so just thinking through
both of those things anyways that has
been really helpful for me in starting
and cueing myself to do new behaviors
that I want to do and then also stopping
behaviors that I don't want to do very
nice most distractions come dressed as
easy opportunities oh yeah this is
interesting because as people begin to
accumulate the success that they say
that they want this becomes an
increasingly big problem
yeah
um I think it was Andy Grove who said
this probably Churchill
um there we are showing another one up
for Winston it might have been Packard I
think I've actually been Hewlett Packard
it might be one of those guys
um he said that businesses die of
indigestion not starvation
and so they overeat they're not starving
it's the entrepreneur that and this is
like you go back to human behavior which
almost all roads lead back to it but
the entrepreneurs get reinforced for
changing direction because nothing
worked nothing worked nothing worked you
change that direction Something clicks
and so what happens is you learn a
lesson from that you're like oh so if I
change direction good things happen
but that's not the right lesson which is
one of my favorite things about
entrepreneurship is making sure that we
learn the right lesson from this from
the from the instance or the
circumstance it's like I hired a sales
guy he did a bad job all sales guys suck
not the right lesson right but that's
actually something that it is pervasive
in even the internet community of like
lessons that people they'll tell the
story and then they'll say the lesson
but sometimes the less all we know is
the facts of what happened not
necessarily the thing you took from it
anyways
um I was making a point Churchill start
instruction easy opportunity so
the the the higher up in business you
get the more attractive the
opportunities that you have to learn to
say no to and this has been really hard
for me because at every level like I
thought great I have I can check the box
on distractions I've learned to say no
to ten thousand dollar opportunities but
then when you're when you're making a
hundred thousand dollars then you have
to be able to say no to 100 000
opportunities and the thing is I called
the woman in the red dress but the woman
in the red dress have you heard this
like this little analogy I have no okay
this is like one of my favorite
analogies so in The Matrix
Morpheus takes them through a training
program to teach them one thing about
agents and so they're walking down the
street and there's all these people
going going and he says were you
listening to me or are you looking at
the woman in the red dress and he says
look again he looks back and the woman
in the red dress you walk by is an agent
putting a gun in his head and
I see distractions the same way which is
that the better you become the more
attractive the woman in the red dress is
and so you can say no to a six but what
about a seven what about a 12. exactly
what about hypothetical thousand yeah
right like that's that's really what it
becomes because there is no limit on the
upside and so
that's why having like some of the Soft
Stuff of like this is the vision this is
what we're trying to do and there's a
hundred other things I could do but each
of the cost of those things is the one
thing that matters most and I think that
one of the things that Layla has been so
good at helping me with and I think a
lot of My Success earlier on was
propelled by the fact that like when I
met Laila I had a chiropractor agency I
had a dental agency I had five gym
locations
I had a gym launch business where we did
turnarounds I had all of those things
going on and there was no CEO besides me
a CEO of all of them because I didn't
understand how this stuff worked and and
I also made no actually I mean I made
money from all of them but no income
like everything was just enough to break
even it was nine spinning plates and
it's because like I was so opportunistic
and it's very classic new entrepreneur
to just say yes to everything and
Warren Buffett said that
the difference between really successful
people and the most successful people
this is me paraphrasing is that the most
successful people say no to almost
everything
and I've tried to take that because it's
so hard and I think that a lot of the
you know it's so simple and so hard
which a lot of success habits are which
is like if you do the same thing for a
very long period of time
I think this is Neil uh
shushing I can't remember the name but
I'll I'll say that yes Churchill again
um he said success comes down to doing
the obvious thing for an extraordinary
period of time without convincing
yourself you're smarter than you are
and I just love that quote why do you
not need to convince yourself that
you're smarter than you are doing the
same thing I think it's because you
think you can handle both and so you're
like oh I got uh okay because if you did
think that you were smarter than you are
you would then start to take on more
stuff so quote from John Maxwell which I
absolutely adore that says you cannot
overestimate the unimportance of
practically everything
but she's just [__] perfect and it's
the call it was so uh Greg mcewen's
essentialism is one of my top five books
of all time and it's for this precise
reason that it's an antidote to the type
A Fallout right I can do it all I will
do it all watch me suffer and bear this
burden and you're like look you can do
the hard work thing right you can you
can do that but the working hard and
being spread thin are two different
Dynamics and one of the one of the like
interesting idea I've been playing
around with a little bit recently is
periodizing uh work so in the same way
as your weightlifting coach we'll have
the guys doing his sub Max for 90 days
he is building up for 90 days he has
comp prep he is blah blah blah blah blah
whatever it is mobility
um that's a much easier way to
um blend what we're talking about here
as maybe a little bit earlier I think
you need to specialize more as you get
bigger and bigger because the
distractions are going to be even
greater especially how so so if you are
uh the CEO of your company and then
someone comes in with you've got so much
more Downstream from you that if you get
distracted the repercussions the
ramifications of becoming distracted are
magnified even more what do you think
about that do you agree I I think the
The Specialist piece is the piece that
threw me because I always feel like the
the higher up you go the more generalist
you become in terms of skill set but not
in terms of projects or in terms of
projects specialized in projects
generalizing skills there we go yeah yes
I like that we'll get back to talking to
Alex in one second but first I need to
tell you about HubSpot 28 of some
people's weeks are spent reading
deleting and sorting emails which means
that very much email is not dead
starting an email newsletter means that
you've got direct connection with your
audience it means that you actually own
your audience it is the only way that
you can own them without going through a
third party like a social media platform
and from HubSpot right now you can
download their free email template that
will teach you how to make your own
newsletter you can learn how to build an
amazing email newsletter from scratch
that will check out a compiled lookbook
of awesome examples from real
Publications you can learn what it takes
to create a successful email newsletter
with exceptional design unique and
compelling copy clickable calls to
action and excellent user experience and
there is a step-by-step guide about how
to get your newsletter launched so if
you've been thinking I want to start
doing a newsletter this sounds cool this
sounds like a good way for me to start
writing to build an audience that I can
then sell to or I can then move to other
platforms as well this is a fantastic
place to begin all that you need to do
to download this free guide that will
take you from no email newsletter to a
fantastically designed email newsletter
using industry inside information all
that you need to do is head to
clickhubspot.com Modern wisdom that's
clickhubspot.com modern wisdom to
download your free email template today
the first step to achieving a massive
dream is Conquering tiny impulses
I think it's exactly what we were
talking about earlier it's like if you
like
I I got a there's a a tweet that I made
actually you
you were the one who made it go viral
right uh which was uh when you quoted me
quoting you to David Gogan yeah it's
just this endless Human Centipede of
[__] homozy quotes
um but he's like you don't you don't uh
you don't feel confident by shouting
affirmations in the mirror but by
stacking
Oh by having an undeniable stack of
proof that you are who you say thank you
that's work yourself down thank you
I'll quote you to you which is a new a
new low
so so that right yeah
um a lot of people were like no but what
if you don't have any successes like how
do you get started and I still think
that the the quote is 100 valid it's
that they don't realize the validity of
the smaller things that they have done
up to that point and so it's being able
to transfer your successes of like okay
like did you get dressed this morning
like did you did you get in front of the
computer like you have evidence it's
smaller evidence but you have enough
evidence to make the claim that you can
do this and then you do that enough
times that you have enough evidence to
make a claim that you can do this and
support it and I think um that's where
the
big outcomes come from lots of of
constrained tiny impulses of saying like
you know what I'm gonna get this tiny
Victory and I know how to say no to that
I noticed a hair say no to heroin today
or whatever yep um that would be a hard
one you know a lot you're implicit
probably larger
um but that's the idea is just stacking
as many of those
pieces of evidence that give you proof
that you are who you say you are that
you can you have done what you say you
can do yeah it's uh
the the challenge of action or belief
first is something that I've been
playing around with so much and my
friend James he wrote a book uh the c
word like confidence it was a book about
how to be confident right and um I do
feel like a a big footnote summary could
have been that quote from you and the
problem is this is something that I've
seen as well a good example coming from
a world where I was successful in
business before I was successful
personally
um I have a skill set now and my
capacity within this particular skill
set and the performance of what that
does are intrinsically linked right
there's almost a linear relationship as
I become better at networking with
guests with recording with doing all of
the other things the show increases when
I run a business there were so many
degrees of freedom between my inputs to
the business and the success of the
business that someone with uh like
malignant imposter syndrome could always
explain away how things had gone well so
I would say oh it's because we timed the
market right oh it was because of like
this member of staff that we brought in
I mean I trained him but really he would
have been great without me or whatever
and um self-doubt can sort of wheel its
way in in very sort of Nefarious ways
when you do that
um then switching to something where you
have a relatively undeniable stack of
proof even undeniable to the part of you
that wants to deny proof right which is
that imposter syndrome
after a little while it's just a
crushing weight that you cut I call it
imposter adaptation so you know if you
continue to disprove your imposter
syndrome in the real world and it
persists you have to admit to yourself
that it's got nothing to do with your
capabilities and everything to do with
your addiction to feeling like an
imposter this is just a trend of how you
think about the world you're looking for
competent you have competence without
confidence which is a lack of belief and
confidence without competency
self-delusion right so you need to have
this balance between the two but people
when they say well surely self-belief
becomes before action I'm like well not
particularly not if that's not your
nature I don't think like you're asking
for delusion there and it is
significantly easier for you to think I
am a fitness person if you just went to
the gym and did 10 push-ups then I am a
fitness person when I go to the gym
tomorrow and do 10 push-ups like where's
the show me spit and sawdust where's the
[__] reality of this you know
I agree good
opportunities only look like
opportunities in the rear view mirror
today they look like Risk how does
someone get around this this
um asymmetry between the fact that in
retrospect it seemed totally obvious and
yet the thing that you're looking at
right now looking forward you go that
might not be obvious in retrospect again
it's tough because um
a lot a lot of the big wins you know
like like Uber's the classic example
right like let's start a business where
strangers pick up girls who are 16 you
don't even drive them to their friend's
house it's like that sounds like a
terrible idea right like it just it but
in retrospect you're like no it'll be
totally fine because there's going to be
a mutual rating system and blah blah
blah right taking out the fact that
there are people who've been captured
and whatever anyway what we'll put that
to the side right
um and the thing is is like just because
we're on the investing side what we
found is that there are always reasons
to say no to a deal
you can always find reasons to say no
because there's nothing that's risk-free
even treasuries have risk the US economy
could collapse and treasury could be
worth nothing like and you could create
a really compelling argument lots of
influencers spent a lot of time doing
that right
um
is it likely
maybe I don't know but it's probably
less likely than than a bank failing
because if the US fails all the banks by
default are also failing so which one
you know which of these is greater risk
so then it gets then you start comparing
risks rather than trying to eliminate
risks and so if we're looking at
opportunities that's why I like Risk
adjusted return is one of the things
that a lot of investors look at which is
like is there a way that I can
appropriately adjust this risk to
normalize different opportunities and I
think that that single skill set is
one of if not the most important
important skill sets as an entrepreneur
because fundamentally it's betting like
that's what we're doing we're making
bets every day we bet with our time we
bet their money
um with the limited constraints we have
or limited resources we have against
unlimited opportunities
because that's the hard part is that
there is unlimited women in the red
dress now there's some fours and there's
some sixes and there's some eights but
you have to both rape the girl right the
opportunity and then also how crazy is
she right or whatever you know whatever
risk factor you want to you know
associate with this is you going to stab
me in my sleep I don't know right does
she have a crazy ex-boyfriend I don't
know about I don't know right and so
that's why we do the diligence process
but like the
the way that we because I just just tied
up this chapter in the book that's
coming out is when we're organizing
opportunities that we're going to pursue
with a business we look at what are the
ones that we have the absolute highest
likelihood of success that we we need no
new skills and no new effort if we can
do that or the least amount of new
effort and no new skills that would be
the first thing we're going to do and
then once we take off all the ones that
take basically no effort and no extra
skills we're like okay which ones take
more effort and still no skills and then
once we do that then we're like okay now
we can start learning a new skill and of
the different skills that we could learn
which of these is going to give us the
highest leverage as in most output for
the least amount of input and that's
pretty much how we tick down which of
these opportunities we want to pursue
because those have the lowest likelihood
of not happening
does this work in the personal world as
well this one is an investor that isn't
in business that's just thinking about
life opportunities do I want to learn to
salsa dance or code I think that the
investor frame
is a is is simply people who have been
scored and Quantified on their ability
to make decisions and so I think that we
can learn a ton from how investors make
decisions overall it's like why Ray
dalio's book principles became like a
bestseller even though 99.9 of people
reading the book aren't even investors
or definitely not investors at his level
but the principles of good decision
making are just Quantified and we have a
scoreboard for these guys being
excellent decision makers whereas most
other people you don't have a real
scoreboard so we can't tell how valid is
their advice and I think that's what
makes uh taking advice from really
world-class investors who've been doing
it for decades
um as a great source of information
because we can validate that they have a
stack of undeniable proof that they are
who they say they are very nice okay so
this was not Churchill this time so this
was this is something that I've actually
relied on a little bit myself uh
whenever I get to a low point where I
think why do I even bother I just remind
myself this is where most people stop
and this is why they don't win and this
relates to another one which is a
reminder for the Gladiators in the arena
who feel beat up and scarred with no
hope in sight building a business is
hard hard feels shitty this is what hard
feels like and this is why most people
can't do it but you can this is what
hard feels like
is so [__] nice to lean on it is so
nice to lean on take me through that low
Point there's actually a story I'm
getting a little Goosebumps telling that
so
um I was way back in my day
um like you a party party promoter but I
was in a fraternity so I was president
of fraternity and this was my first
semester being president and so you have
a pledge class you get two pledge
classes as a person you get a fall and a
spring and then that's your your tenure
and then another president comes in and
what we knew and this would be really
interesting for the audience from a
human behavior perspective is that like
clockwork
every time we start a new pledge class
within 14 days 10 to 14 it was like
clockwork they would all get together
and they'd revolt and they'd say we
don't want to do it anymore this is what
we signed up for this is way [__]
harder than we thought it was going to
be like we thought we was going to party
with you guys like that's what we
expected which also shows you how long
it takes people to adapt or acclimate to
a very a significantly more difficult
situation right
I'll tell you what happens after and
then I'll tell you what happened in
between
after we have this kind of talk that we
had and I'll tell you how I how I
explained it when I was President
um all of a sudden it all vanishes
because their expectations of reality
have come completely reset we break
reality
like in the first 10 to 14 days it's so
painful for them because it's such a
contrast
not the fun stuff but what's not fun oh
my God I mean they can't drink can't
talk to girls the only people they could
talk to are brothers or each other and
we're mean to them so they could really
only talk to each other and the whole
point is that we're trying to get them
close together because there's a bunch
of dudes who don't know each other from
different parts of the campus right and
we have to get them in eight to twelve
weeks to leave as one unit of people who
know everything about one another that
trust one another that know everything
of the other people in the house so it's
like how do you do that well there's
only x amount of communication you can
have every day so let's cut out anybody
who's not us okay and then if we really
want them to be close together we'll
also reinforce that we're mean but part
of what they had to do is they had to
learn everything about everyone else in
the house and so every pledge has to do
something that would impress a brother
and then they get a signature from their
brother being like I approve of you and
you have to get every single brother's
signature by the time you're done right
and so that's where each of those side
quests become as insane as you might
imagine right and there's lots of you
know there was lots of hazing back in
the day which is not fun and you know a
lot of sleepless nights and things like
that and you go from like partying with
girls from like your top of the world
all these brothers feeding you drinks
being like be like you're awesome dude
to then like the next day and this is
literally how it happens this is how
like the break in reality happens we do
this huge party to like launch the new
class and the next morning they all wake
up they're all like they all sleep at
the house because that's one of the
requirements
and they're all hungover and got their
ties like vomit in the corner or
whatever and we're like great clean it
up and they're like what because up to
this point they haven't cleaned after a
party because all they did is got to
parties see the girls and then leave
but then all of a sudden they're like
mopping bottom in the corner and they're
hungover and they feel terrible and
they're like what the [__] this is what
I signed up for right so anyways two
weeks of this they get together and they
wanted me to meet them and this always
happens because they want to meet on
their their Turf and I'm like all right
guys what's up and so it's just me all
right and my vice president and like 25
guys so there's like a you know there's
like a size comparison of like just
animalistically there's way more of them
than there is of me
and so I just asked them a couple
questions I was like who here before
pledging started was like I want to be a
part of this house the guys are like you
know me okay like okay got it
who here thought it was going to be easy
all right who here thought it would be
hard
they raised their hands I'm like guys
this is what hard feels like
and all of a sudden there's just like
this big exhale in the room they're like
expectations get reset this is normal
you wanted this thing you expect it to
be hard reality now matches conditions
so our expectations now match conditions
this is what heart feels like
and then all of a sudden it's like they
got permission to feel shitty and by
getting permission to feel shitty they
stop feeling shitty because they're like
this is just my new world
and so then you know you're like listen
you give eight weeks you're gonna get
three and a half years other people are
going to drive you around late at night
other people want to clean after you
like it's a good investment right and
that it was a good deal like you give
one semester and you get the rest of
them to just do whatever you want
um
but that concept like that quote on both
of those came from that experience of
having someone tell me this is what
heart feels like
this is where most people stop and this
is why they don't win is also another
beautiful bit of motivation and given
that I spent a little bit of time with
Goggins and cam Hanes two guys I was
telling you about this before you said
must be nice as we walked in so Cameron
Haynes bowhunter extraordinaire lives in
Oregon and he has behind the power Rack
in his garage where he left he has must
be nice written and I was like why why
have you got that put up on there and he
was like it's because everyone says it
must be nice to be you Cam must be nice
to be sponsored by height and all of
these like top level bow things and go
on Rogan he was uh there was a video
that went super viral of Goggins losing
his [__] after Jon Jones won last
weekend uh and the guy that he's hugging
his cam so it's like it must be nice for
you to be backstage at UFC you must be
nice for this and I've seen what that
guy does and that guy picks up a rock
that weighs about 80 pounds and it's got
the word poser written on the front of
it because people call him a poser and
he carries it up a hill that is Maybe
Maybe
like a thousand foot of elevation mile
and a half high with no Fanfare at the
end no Finish Line doesn't post it on
social media unless the team's there
filming it with someone else and then
carries it back down puts it in the boot
of his Raptor drives away and he just
does that because he needs to remind
himself that he's doing the stuff that
is hard and this is where most people
stop and this is why they don't win
combined with this is what hard feels
like justifies things being hard now
I do worry and I find this in myself
sometimes as well that you can
be so good at dealing with suffering
that you can actually push yourself a
little bit too far and you go I'm
starting to Bear more burden than I can
basically take on and the Art of not
burning out is something that I think a
lot of people if you if this resonates
with you
the art of not burning out is something
that you really really need to be able
to feel and like realizing what happens
when you just start to glance off the
bottom side of it and go okay like I'm
just gonna ease off the gas so that I
need to take this afternoon to go sauna
and get some sunshine and chill out and
get some food and then I can put my foot
back on maybe a little bit tomorrow and
we'll temper it
um but just it it justifies the fact
that
I use this stat all the time 90 of
podcasts don't make it past episode
three and of the 90 of the 10 that do 90
don't make it past episode 20. so by
making 21 podcasts you're in the top
percentile of all podcasters ever in
history
that's what hard feels like and that's
not even hard it's just consistent [__]
me it's less than half a year yeah
insane I hear stats like that and I just
think man it is so easy to win
like that I mean like when I hear that
that's exactly what I think I'm just
like man
for everyone's like struggling to win
it's like you like most of the pain that
people experience is purely in their own
minds and so to your point I think
there's an interesting one between like
burnout versus hard
and so like for me burnout is when my I
would Define it as my output per unit of
time decreases
so I can see that that's measurable
right
now like I can say like number of pages
that I edit or the quality of the
content that I create like my output
like the team knows when I like when I'm
like six hours seven hours into
recording something they're like I
literally start like slumping you're
like like physically I just start like
slumping and I like my my Cadence isn't
as like I'm just not as sharp right
there's that versus
emotional burnout which I think people
mislabel as burnout when really it's
just like they don't know how to reframe
reality
and so what it really is is they got a
comment on a post that bugged them
and like again it's like pulling it from
the Shadows it's like no this stuff
doesn't work it's like hold on what's
the one voice that actually is coming
through what is the real thing well
there's this comment okay great it's
embarrassing to even have to say that
but when you say it then you admit it
and all of a sudden you put it in the
light and the shame kind of starts to
evaporate because then you can name it
and be like is this comment better than
my bigger than my future is this comment
bigger than me
and one of the things that I um
that has helped me was saying like
what's true about this we'll get back to
Alex in one minute but first I need to
tell you about seed seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic is one of the most advanced
probiotic and prebiotics on the market
it's a 24 strain broad spectrum
probiotic and Prebiotic formulated for
Digestive gut immune and additional
system benefits with 53.6 billion AFU
it's a two-in-one via Cap Technology
capsule encapsule protects against
stomach acid digestive enzymes and bile
salts for viability through your
digestion it means that the probiotics
will actually make it to the end of the
small intestine for delivery which
massively increases how successful this
is going to be for you altogether it
means that your digestion is going to
move more smoothly so if you've been
thinking that you want to make an
upgrade to your digestion you've been
considering using some probiotics and
prebiotics for a while seed is the most
advanced option on the market also you
can get 15 off your first month if you
go to seed.com Modern wisdom and use the
code modern wisdom a checkout that's
s-e-eed.com modern wisdom and modern
wisdom a checkout
are you familiar with Byron Katie do you
know her I've heard her name yeah the
work she does the work and um the one of
the first questions that she asks you is
uh is it true how do you know that it
can be true yeah and so it's like the
same thing bring it from the Shadows
right into the light okay you have this
sense there's no [__] it's like a
[__] smell it's like yeah
maybe something's a bit maybe
something's maybe I might be like a
piece of [__] maybe I'm not competent
maybe I'm not whatever you go okay let's
and the next one is like what if we
confront it and say like what if they're
right
now what
because a lot of I think a lot of effort
gets put into trying to deny deny
reality right like there's this clip
that I shared uh from Tom Billy and he
was talking about how he gets made fun
of for his ears being big right and I
think it's a really good clip because
his point that he was making because
it's such a visual easy example for
people to understand
um he's like is that it's true I do have
big ears
and
and so that's that's like the if they're
like you have no right to be making
content are they right okay
and yeah I'm still gonna do it anyways
because the thing is like I one of the
things that I had earlier on in my
career was like I didn't think I was a
really good person like I was like I'm
not a good person yeah like some people
like yeah I just had that right and I
had a history you know whatever
and one of the things that gave me a lot
of respite or relief from that kind of
thought process was like comma that's
okay because I can still do the things
that create success and not deserve it
and still get it
and that actually felt very powerful for
me because it was like I don't have to
deserve to success I can still just do
the stuff that gets it it's like you
don't have to you don't have to deserve
the girl but you can still do the things
I get her
and do you deserve it when you have her
I don't know who knows I hate the word
deserve to begin with right yes
but like that concept because also I
could segue into like gratitude around
like if you think you deserve it then
you don't you don't enjoy it but
um that has been super powerful for me
which is like what if they're right
and
because a lot of people just trying they
spend so much effort trying to fight the
fact that the comments might be right
this might have been a [__] terrible
thumbnail you know what this might have
been a boring video this this post might
have been regurgitated content this post
might have been inspired too closely by
someone else's post right
what if they're right and yeah does it
make me a piece of [__]
what if it does and
you end up getting down to base which is
pretty much nothing right all that there
is is actions all that there is is what
you're going to do in response to this
you know what another brilliant uh
add addition to this that you kind of
mentioned yeah which is uh the fact that
this is what hard feels like most people
get to this stage and they decide to
stop and now the bar is set so low
Goggins said this in the episode with me
and it gave me chills when he said it he
was like it's so easy to be successful
nowadays because people are weak yeah
everybody's weak Dana White says it as
well I tell my kids it is so easy if you
are even a like weekend Savage you will
run these kids over yeah and for every
single person it's giving me chills
again for every single person that
likes to castigate the very padded
victimhood mentality of the modern world
okay cool like you can you can rail
against people that say that the world
is against them even though it's not and
etc etc
how does that inform the way that you
should operate in the world right well
okay what you're saying is everybody
else it is
fallible weak fragile in some way or
another how does that inform the way
that you act the way that you should act
is holy [__] if I have even a modicum of
resilience right this makes the market
environment for me so much easier
whether I want to get the Girl by the
house become successful in whatever
domain I choose to the bar is set solo
yeah
this uh if we're going if we're going
tweets
um this segues into one of my favorite
ones which is uh you stay in poverty
until you learn the first lesson of
poverty which is two words my fault
and so
when I was younger I was really angry at
my parents like many people are right
Justified or not doesn't really matter I
was very angry and I blamed them for the
woes of my life
and I realized when I was 19 that these
people that I hated
I was giving all the power over the fact
that I wasn't the person I wanted to be
and I was like well it's their fault
and the idea that I had actually given
these people that I hated power over
My Success
was ultimately something that made me
feel sick to my stomach and was what
allowed me to point the finger of blame
inwards
and say my fault and then at least take
ownership over the fact that like
and like sure maybe your dad didn't hug
you enough or maybe your mom was in
present or whatever it is right it's
like and and like I said this the other
day and it'll probably piss off a lot of
your audience so you know we can put our
soft earphones on
um like if you were if you if you
suffered from racial inequality if
you've suffered from gender inequality
if you suffered from being born in
Bangladesh if you were racist sexually
abused your entire life
you would be completely justified in the
fact that you are not achieving the
things that other people who didn't have
those disadvantages have achieved and I
say this as a white guy who was born in
America to a doctor father
I understand that but at the same degree
you have the opportunity that
Chris nor I have which is that you can
be an inspiration of people who just who
went through the same thing and
succeeded comma despite those
circumstances because I can promise that
there is somebody who has had it worse
and has done it better
and I think that that one single point
of proof and like there's a global point
of proof that you can look for for sure
but like you can be that very local
point of proof in your community or sub
community and I think um
as soon as we shed that that's like I
just I'm a big fan of uh Power follows
the blame finger
so like wherever you point the blame
fingers where the power follows and so
it's like if you point us if you point
it to the government government has the
power if you point it at your your
spouse and say like it's their fault
that I'm not in shape it's their fault
they never let me do anything it's like
well
you're giving them all the power and so
it's like until you're like it's my
fault it's also responsibility what is
what if it's not your fault
it doesn't matter and
hmm
like I can't run marathons because I
lost my leg at Birth
and
either you can just never try or you put
the metal thing on
and you do it anyways so this is one of
the themes that I'm very interested in
to do with your work in general and it's
one of the reasons why it Bridges the
Gap from what we're going through which
are you know some really lovely
philosophical insights and all of the
rest of it the difference is
you seem to have a knack to be able to
drag yourself out of the philosophy and
get yourself into action
there's not too much mental masturbation
that goes on so let's say that there's
someone who's listening to this podcast
you know thousands of people that are
listening who are that person Millions
thousands of people that are that person
there'll be a lot of people that are
listening don't worry
um
that person that goes I I love when I
hear these aphorisms and and things and
maybe it goes on the Whiteboard that's
on the front of my fridge for a couple
of months how does that person get from
mental masturbation yeah around it to
action that this this impact my life in
a tangible way that actually makes a
difference to me any of the things that
we go through today all right two things
one is knowing the input output equation
the second is knowing what your fuel is
going to be so if you can't define the
inputs and outputs that are going to get
you what you want then there's no way to
start right because you don't know what
you're supposed to do so you have to
Define it down to like the most basic
first action so it's like if I want to
start creating content that means I have
to post something if it means I have to
start doing cold I always think in terms
of business because that's what I'm in
but like I'm either doing a cold reach
out I'm doing a cold call cold email
cold DM whatever that is I have to make
a piece of content I have to post it and
make a podcast I have to make a YouTube
video to make a short whatever that is
make a blog post
um I have to run an ad right I have to I
have to run the ad I have to press go I
have to spend the money whatever it is
like whatever that core initial action
go to the gym lift the weight put the
shoes on whatever the input is you have
to Define what the input is that's going
to get you the output you want now once
you know what that input output is the
next one is why aren't you doing it
right and so I think a lot of people are
looking for something
that is very hard to find and so and
then they attribute their lack of
success or lack of action because they
don't have passion or motivation right
and I was the same way and so uh the
short story around this was that I uh I
watched all the TED talks in college
like that was like what I was like I'm
not watching YouTube I'm watching TED
talks and I was like and then I realized
and then I heard the term mental
masturbation and I was like oh that's
definitely what I've done
I was like my life hasn't changed at all
and then I got my jobs out of college
and I would read all the self-help books
like every night that's all I did I just
read all these self-help books and I
found one of them
that said there are people who are
entrepreneurs and entrepreneurs
and I remember hearing that word
entrepreneur and I was like it made me
feel sad I was like I want to be [__]
watch Brothers like I'm not some [__]
like like but but I was like but what if
they're right
I am a entrepreneur I'm not an
entrepreneur I want to be one and I'm
not and from that point it took me six
months to quit my job to actually decide
to do the entrepreneurial thing and the
thing there are many things that
contributed to me being able to leave
and I think a lot of it's not like we
were looking for one thing it might be a
big bag of wise a lot of them right that
add up together to be above your action
threshold and
I think in the early days people are
looking for the big carrot they want the
big Vision they want the big passion
but they don't have it but I want to
I'll give you the first rule of
Entrepreneurship that I've learned which
is use what you have and a lot more
people have pain a lot more people have
anger a lot more people have shame and
if you can use that as your gas in the
beginning you'll eventually get to a
point where you can get out of that Loop
and then find something that you are
really passionate about but if you can't
tie your shoes you can't lift the weight
you can't send the DM then you have to
start with whatever you have and so for
me it was hatred of my current existence
I hated being an entrepreneur I hated
being a wannabe I hated being one of
those people who like talked about all
the things they were going to do and
didn't do anything
um
I hated living
the life that my dad wanted me to live I
was I was his [__] that's what it was I
was his [__] I was living his dreams
out not mine and that was you know led
to that other tweet which was um
sometimes your parents dreams have to
die in order for yours to live
and
for me I realized that the idea that my
father had of me as his son that image
had to die
in order for the image of myself that I
wanted to be to live because I kept
trying to quit my job and go be an
entrepreneur and every time I'd have the
conversation be like ah come over we'll
talk about it we'll have dinner you know
what and he'd always talk me off the
ledge it was always over and over again
salesman yeah and or great authoritarian
you don't need to persuade when you have
compliance
um and so
uh and so everybody has that person or
or it might actually be somebody who's
talking off the ledge or might should be
a voice in your head doesn't really
matter because that that voice in person
that only happened once or twice
probably keeps talking to you when
you're at home
um but the big thing for me when I when
I decided to make the jump and mind you
I was such a [__] about it that I I had
to drive across the country before I
called him to tell him that I left yeah
I remember like I didn't want to yeah I
didn't want to confront him
um which he then like flew off the
handle about
um but
I just knew and this is the Tony Robbins
quote but it's just when the pain of
staying the same is greater than the
pain of change and I think that
I think pain moves people far far more
effectively than pleasure does like the
easy thing to wait to prove it is like
point a gun at someone's head and you
have absolute compliance and they will
do what they need to do right
automatically just like that
like death is the great motivator and
the gun just reminds you
and so I think that if you can create
the figurative gun to your head of the
pain that you're experiencing and then
I'm a big fan of future casting out
negative scenarios so people talk about
like positive visualization I prefer a
negative visualization which is what if
I keep doing what I'm currently doing
for the next 10 years will my life look
like then that usually takes my current
pain and then just magnifies it and then
that allows me to get my action
threshold high enough that it goes over
the edge so that I can take that first
move and so if you know what the inputs
outputs are of what you need to do the
guy who has the little quote on his wall
and you figure out whatever fuel you've
got not the one you wish you had but the
one you've got and you use that to do
the first input you cross the line
you're in the game
I told the story on the episode that I
did with Goggins about bullying in
school and this was something where I
like opened up about a topic that I
haven't spoken about a ton because it
made me feel weak and it made me feel
vulnerable and so on and so forth
but
one of the things that's only really
recently happened and it's actually been
assisted by the guy that reached out and
messaged me this dude messaged and said
that he was sorry for what had happened
his daughter was going to school and it
reflect made him reflect on his time
um at school and how he treated me and
he was like dude I just wanted to say
that I'm sorry I don't even know if
you're going to see this I'm happy that
you seem to be happy but you know I I
just had to get it off my chest and that
really helped not that I was carrying
much yeah but one of the questions you
know you've spoken about your dad in
this kind of like authoritarian
relationship and living out that dream
how
did you
avoid or how have you got yourself to a
stage now where you're no longer driven
by a chip on your shoulder toward him
because I think that there are a lot of
people that go through challenges in
their past yeah that you find fuel in it
and they go wow I can be filled by
hatred yeah phenomenal I can alchemize
this toxic thing into something which is
useful totally
but
I would imagine that that has a a shelf
span right that if you keep on using
that for long enough there are more
optimal ways that you could start to
move perpetually under your own motion
transmuted into something else how did
you get past having this chip on your
shoulder about the relationship that
you'd had with your dad and where it had
set you back or forward or whatever
um
or have you
yeah I think I have
um I think my realization was you know
first the goal was make as much as my
dad then it was make more than my dad
then it was making more than my dad had
ever made and I realized that the
approval that I had
that I saw it was always going to be
moved right I mean I've told this story
before but maybe not your audience but
like when I when I my dad and I didn't
really speak a ton you know we texted
you know two minute phone call hey
you're alive okay cool
um but for that was kind of like for
like five-ish years
um after I left home uh to go do the gym
thing and only once gym launch was like
printing money
um and so we were I think I was taking
home a million and a half a month at
like 27 or something like that and he
gave me a call out of the blue and like
my dad doesn't like cold call me
um and so I'm sitting at dinner and I
step outside
and he says um hey you're going to want
to sit down for this and I was like okay
he's like I'm sorry I was like about
what he was like
everything
and I remember in the moment actually
feeling nothing
and thinking that was curious and then
being like huh
okay
and I probably should have just like
accepted it for the Olive Branch that he
was probably trying to like lean out to
me um but here's what I said instead I
said you know how
people get up on stage when they win the
awards and they're like I just want to
thank my mom and dad for always being
there always believing me I was like I'm
not going to say that I was like because
you weren't and you didn't believe in me
and
right after that he was like well we'll
see how long it lasts
and so
it was after that phone call that I
realized that everything that I'd done
to that point was to try and beat him at
his game because everything my dad cared
about and not everything he's a good guy
like you know we're fine now but like
when I was growing up and it's fairly
common in most foreign families to be
very like money driven and I always knew
that kind of subconsciously and he would
never say this but like I felt it
because whenever he introduced somebody
he told me how much they made
immediately he'd be like this is John
John makes this like this is Bob he
makes this like it was just it was just
like the worth and the name was like
immediately tied together
and so I realized that I was trying to
win his game rather than playing my game
and I think when that happened it was
the same instance of kind of like the
blame finger but just at a different
level of saying like Okay well I don't
blame my dad anymore but I'm still
playing his game
and so I'm winning not my game I'm
winning someone else's and so I think
when I was like okay well then I have to
define the game and the meaning of the
game that I want to play I have more
responsibility now because I have to
define the rules what matters most to me
Etc
um but that was where I feel like I got
and maybe there's more that I'll unpack
later but that was kind of the next
level at least for my awareness of how I
perceived what I was going after
do you remember you I think you spoke
about people that
break the law in an attempt to make
money and he said uh we sacrificed the
thing we want for the thing that's
supposed to get it so we sacrifice uh
freedom for money in the hopes that the
money will give us freedom yeah
Downstream from that this is one of the
best things that I learned for all of
last year and you created the framework
and then I filled it in so I talked
about the tension between uh success and
the desire to feel like we're enough I
think that this speaks to what you're on
about here success is a strange thing
presumably we want success because we
think a more successful life will bring
us more happiness meaning and
fulfillment is the problem we sacrifice
the thing we want happiness for the
thing which is supposed to get it
success failure can make you miserable
but I'm not sure that success will make
you happy and if you end up with an
equation if you could imagine like we
sacrifice happiness to achieve success
in the pursuit of happiness like if you
just remove success from both sides of
the equation what are you left with it's
just happiness there are um
we can't deny the fact that we're
statusful beings that we you know we
require external validation we can't
just you know go and live in a cave and
in peaceful Bliss and all the rest of it
like there are things that we need to do
but I do feel like a lot of the time we
overclock our lives with regards to
success and the Pursuits that we go
through in an attempt to to do this and
that uh we sacrifice the thing we want
for the thing which is supposed to get
it is like
I see that all the time I always ask
myself am I over complicating this like
am I am I doing more than I need to do
is there a simpler way to do this
I think um
I mean I think this is a actually a game
theory thing
um and you're from okay so I can I can I
can go on it or I cannot if you want
I'll bring it on Bring It On yeah so I
mean Simon sinek popularized this but
you're finite in infinite games right
finite games where you have no known
players agreed upon rules
um and an outcome that that wins the
game right uh and then infinite game you
have known and unknown players no rules
and the point of the game is to keep the
game going and what happens is that
people apply finite rules to infinite
games and then they wonder why it's not
working as an example
so a final game would be like baseball
no the players at the end of the game
the person you tally up the ones with
the most runs and you win and there's
you can't you can't run you can't hold
the ball and run it around the bases
like there's rules of play
with an infinite game
the Vietnam War isn't a simple example
that Simonson net gives which is
basically the US lost the Vietnam War
because they were they were applying a
finite structure which is we're going to
win this war and the Vietnamese people
were were playing an infinite game
structure which is we're going to stay
alive and keep fighting and as long as
someone is staying alive and keeping
fighting they will beat the person who's
trying to end something and so the
infinite frame always conquers the
finite and the thing is is that most of
the games worth playing are infinite and
so if you're trying to get in shape you
don't win getting in shape the point is
to stay in shape for the rest of your
life you don't win at marriage the point
is to stay married you don't win at
business the point is to stay in
business and keep doing business so the
point of the game is to keep playing I
think if if the six and I would imagine
success if you put all of those things
together it's an infinite game and so
the point of success is to do the things
that make you successful and so if
you're doing the things that are making
you successful then you are by
definition winning and I think that for
me redefining what is a perfect day
and living as many of those days in a
row as I possibly can to me that's
winning and I and obviously have a
relatively contrary in world view but
which is that like when we die nothing
happens and you know we know what it was
like to die because we've all been dead
before which is when we were before we
were alive
um but I don't think that what I will do
will ultimately matter in 500 million
years and so that kind of eliminates a
lot of the pressure for me around like
the external outcome sure I'm human
there are definitely motivators but if I
can just over time chip away at how much
that weighs on the scale and I can keep
putting more and more coins on the other
side
towards the infinite game of like the
point of the game is to keep playing and
like there are some things that I remind
myself over and over again this is like
the point of the games to keep playing
that's the point that is the point is to
just keep playing the point of the game
is to keep playing I very much like that
what was that you found out um the three
trait the three most common traits of
Highly Successful People do you remember
those yeah it was um it's so funny
superiority conflicts so the three most
common traits of hyper successful people
that they looked at and it was
interesting because there's
the influencer world wants to be like
you have to wake up at five or you have
to do cold plunges or whatever the [__]
right but the thing that but there was
actually very few that they all had in
common so number one was that they had a
superiority complex they thought they
were better than other people and that
they deserved more
the second is that they suffered from
massive insecurity and feeling that they
would never be enough
and third they had impulse control
and so you've got this combination of
people who are like I want to do this
big thing so this big toward thing and
they've got this big away pain that's
like I'm never gonna be enough I always
have to do more and then they have
impulse control that keeps them focused
on the goal
without seeing the woman in the red
dress or getting pursued by her and that
like
so it's like shoot High have a big thing
that that motivated like have a big
tiger behind you and stay on the path
have you ever heard uh Jordan Peterson
talk about that study of starving rats
in a tube with a spring attached to this
no [__] brilliant this is this is
what you're talking about so
um starving rats are placed into a tube
yeah and they have a spring that is
attached to the tail that can measure
the force that they pull out and that's
a proxy for desire then they waft the
smell of cheese in from the front of the
tube and the rat poles and they measure
how hard they want to go and you think
these rats are starving they'll be
pulling pretty hard then they do another
iteration of the study this time they
waft the smell of cheese in from the
front but they waft the smell of a cat
in from behind and the Rats pull harder
yeah and what's the lesson that you'd
not only need to run towards something
that you want yeah but you need to run
away from something that you fear yeah
the problem and this is I like super
superiority complex crippling insecurity
impulse control right I like that
the problem is
people who we admire the most due to the
most success in the real world
don't necessarily have the most
admirable internal states that to me
isn't necessarily the most peaceful
Blissful way to live your life what does
it say that especially in the modern
world we uh Revere the people who have
external accolades of success and yet
the three most common traits of these
super successful people lead from a
place which is almost objectively
miserable
unadmirable yeah how do we how do we
Square this circle I think it's just
what are we solving for
so
um like I mean a lot of people I love
watching Last Dance which is Michael
Jordan's you know mini docu-series
phenomenal yeah unbelievable
um I think most people could see him
there and be like I don't know if I
really Envy this guy's life like he
still seems like pretty upset despite
being a billionaire despite all the you
know these these these other things and
so I think that if like what are we
solving for like my my closest friend Dr
Kashi he has a statement because he
coached Olympic uh Olympic teams and he
was like Champions are broken
I was like huh he's like they people
look at Champions and try and find
something that that champion has that
they don't have he's like but it's not
that at all he's like they lack
something everyone else has which is an
off button they just don't stop
and
at the end of the day like
if we're if we're optimizing for
outcomes then the most broken person
will win the person who has the absolute
biggest you know desire for achievement
the absolute biggest fear or pain that
they're running away from and the
hardest impulse control now impulse
control most people would agree is a
good thing the other two not as much
and so
what are we optimizing for what problem
are we solving it's my favorite it's
probably the number one most frequently
Asked question that I asked to our
portfolio companies whenever we're about
to do anything which is what problem are
we solving if the problem that we're
solving is that I want to be content
well there's a lot of ways to do that
you don't need to do all these other
things if the problem you're solving is
that you want to be the richest man in
the world
well you're going to have to have a lot
of spirit accomplished you have a lot of
crippling insecurity and you have a lot
of impulse control and you have to wait
a long time
there's a quote from Jason Pagan that
says accept all of your heroes are full
of [__] Your Heroes aren't Gods they're
just regular people who probably got
good at One Thing by neglecting
literally everything else
yeah I just I agree with the statement
[__] money um I it's just so
interesting to me I've been thinking
about this to do with Billy McFarland uh
let me let me just get this in hit it
and that's okay
because if they wanted that then that's
the problem that they're solving for
like I get criticized all the time for
work-life balance people are like well
you don't have any hobbies Alex and you
don't whatever right and I'm like I
don't [__] want any
so why do I have to sacrifice things
that I would prefer to do to do things I
don't want to do to satisfy your
objective measure of what you deem as
work-life balance
why so that's what this is what you were
talking about uh was it optimized for
the outcome or what's the metric of
success uh yeah he was saying like what
is it that people are optimizing for
right
it seems to me that
you have stepped back and decided
axiomatically this is the thing that I'm
optimizing for that I enjoy most doing
yes that's I enjoy playing the game and
so everything I do is about the game yes
my podcast is called the game I draw
pictures all day about business I write
books about business I make content
about businesses I've never seen a
picture offers a zillion pictures in
there oh are they done by you 100 all of
the drawings are mine and 100 leads is
like 100 Doodles in it are you doing
good are they nice I think so are they
are they cute yeah you've got little
animals in yeah they don't have animals
and I'm not I'm not gonna look at them
there's little bag of money big bag of
money like that's how nice dead serious
but no but like and and I spend the rest
of my day doing business
and so it's like
why don't you Garden because I don't
care here's the other thing right I I
always talk about this Steffi Graf um
they one of the greatest female tennis
players of all time and she gets tested
when she's 10 years old 11 years old and
she's in some tennis academy and they
engage the players on two criteria they
gauge them on desire to train
uh and skill set all right and she was
10 out of 10 on both so okay not only
has she got the raw materials to make a
phenomenal tennis player but she'll
outwork you and to her it won't even
feel like work that's [__] terrifying
yeah and that's why I do think for the
people that look at yourself and say uh
Alex is on a road to burn out it's
because you are using your theory of
mind about how you would feel if you had
to work as much as you do but okay what
is the thing that you can do longer than
anybody else and to them it looks like
working to you it looks like play or
feels like play what would that be oh
well for me it would be uh computer
games or knitting or rock music or
whatever okay so imagine if you've just
got to do that all day but instead of it
being rock music it was [__] business
yeah someone commented the other day um
was it you're sprinting on a treadmill
uh they were concerned that the pace
that the show is going out at was going
to cause me to burn out and in
retrospect I'm you know in five years
time I'm like oh [__] yeah I was moving
too quick but I don't think I don't
think that like
I work at the pace that I like to work
at and I also like to see where those
limits are and that's exciting to me to
go okay just how much harder can I go
here and then again you've got to temper
it with that's burnout like that's just
the beginning of it and you only know
that after you've burned out like 30
times uh but that's it's trite to say
after atomic Habits by James clear right
but the intersection of like what you
love to do what you're good at and what
you can be paid for is like slap bang in
the middle of it
slaves worked all the hours they were
awake for their entire lives
in American history in Egyptian history
in the rest of the world that had slaves
which is most of the world at some given
point
I think like if they can do it so can I
now you're like well did they have a
happy existence well they didn't get to
pick the work they did but it means that
you can work that's if you have the cat
behind you you can work every hour of
the day I'm like well if you get to have
the cheese and you get to eat the cheese
the whole way you're going then I mean
there's the famous quote uh you know the
person who the person who loves walking
walks further than the person who loves
the destination right and so like I
think it's the same thing but
the
everyone so many people want to project
their idea of of what they think your
life should be like onto you
and it's just completely irrelevant it
just doesn't matter like if all I did if
I if I weren't married right because
people were like okay well he is married
and like I am in shape
but I also just like working out but if
I didn't have either of those things and
all I did was work all day more people
would talk about the work-life balance
thing for me than they currently do
and who cares
I just like I just I fundamentally am
like you are gonna die and you're not
gonna matter and I'm gonna die and I'm
not gonna matter so why do I care about
what you're gonna say when you're not
even gonna show up to my funeral who
gives a [__]
in other news that has never been about
the time to start an online side hustle
and hosting it is making creating a
website as easy as possible if you're
looking to start your own website or
online shop but don't have the technical
or design skills you can look no further
than hosting it with hostinger you can
launch your own website or online shop
in minutes and Thrive online for 2.99 a
month hosting it provides an all-in-one
website builder domain hosting and
professional email service it's the most
affordable option for getting your
online hustle started and it's
ridiculously simple to use with hosting
it you can launch a WordPress website in
just one click or use their drag and
drop website builder plus you can choose
from over 150 beautiful and fully
customized templates for e-commerce
blogs portfolios landing pages and more
if you need a logo hostinger has got you
covered with their AI logo maker powered
by chat gpt's API you can create a logo
in seconds and make your brand Stand Out
head to hostinger.com
modernwisdom for an extra 10 off if you
use the code modern wisdom at checkout
that's h-o-s-t
inger.com modern wisdom and modern
wisdom a checkout
what is it that you're taking an
enjoyment from then the one step deeper
than this there is something that you're
optimizing for I love I love the reward
what reward the micro rewards I get
every day like of operating a business
of all things business related yep so I
love writing the book about business I
love talking to my editor about what
we're changing oh that's a really way
better way to say it right or I like
tweeting about the thoughts that we have
I love doing discussions like this
because I talk about my favorite topic
which is business for the most part
um like and I actually am pretty averse
to punishment I've learned that about me
like I do not like it and when I say
punish me in the formal sense like
things you don't like right and so like
I avoid them like the plague I don't do
them and so I just do as many of the
things I can that reward me as
frequently as possible but from the
outside to a lot of people that looks
like punishment right
yes interesting how can someone uh cut
through
societal expectations the ways they've
dealt with past trauma expectations from
parents all of the things that aren't
their thing yeah how can somebody
because what you've done again
axiomatically a priori this is the thing
I want to optimize for how do people
find the thing that they want to
optimize for I don't have a thing Alex
that's [__] great for you with your
business it just happens to be something
else that's at the intersection of
making a [__] ton of money yeah how do I
find it I was lucky with that yes that
that just happened to be the
intersection because if I love knitting
and I didn't like business yeah that's a
whole step because like you can turn
knitting into a business but like if I
only like knitting then there's a way to
make a living for that but to to get to
the person who's like uh how do I find
my thing
um
I'm a big fan of being directionally
correct rather than absolutely correct
and so I think what happens is most
people are trying to find the perfect
answer when they have no perspective
from which to make a judgment they're
trying to find the perfect thing to do
and they haven't done anything so how
would you have perspective to make a
judgment
like if you try a lot of things in the
beginning which you have to know what
your inputs outputs are decrease your
action threshold enough with either a
cheese or a cat whatever you need most
people have more cats than they have
cheese in the beginning so use the cat
to start running towards something and
the thing is is the rad it's so simple
it's like there's cheese here but what
you really just need to know is that
there's cheese out there
and there's a cat behind me for sure
and so if I just go anywhere away from
the cat I have a higher likelihood of
getting closer to the cheese not that I
will find it but I will get closer to it
and I think it's and I've lived my life
through a series of Rapid iterations not
trying to pick the right thing because I
just like even when I was starting my
first business I was between frozen
yogurt test prep and a gym those are the
three businesses that I was choosing
makes complete sense yeah right a lot of
things that I like right you know and so
so I'm choosing between those things and
like why were those the things I was
like well I was pretty good at taking
tests in college so I get that I like
frozen yogurt and I mean it sounds
simple but like I was like everybody
likes something right and I actually
didn't know that I was gonna like
business that's the crazy thing because
also hey when you and I were younger
Instagram wasn't there YouTube like none
of this [__] existed and
Entrepreneurship wasn't cool yet and so
I just hated my job a lot and I hated
where I lived a lot and so I was like
well I will just not be here so cat
don't know what city I'm gonna go to but
just not this city I went across the
furthest place from Baltimore which is
California and then I was like okay well
what do I hate doing well let me not do
that which is you know sitting on
meetings all day and doing whatever you
know doing grunt work for [__] that I
felt like was meaningless and instead I
was like I'll do Fitness because I like
Fitness and I was like at the very least
I'll do something I enjoy which I liked
Fitness at the time and if you're like
well I don't like doing anything it's
like well then that's impossible
because
your brain is wired to be rewarded for
things and so you are doing things that
reward you that's why you do them like
everything we do is because we've been
rewarded for doing things like that in
the past and we project the same
activities and we predict that doing
things like we did in the past that
reward us reward us again in the future
that's where our Behavior comes from and
so it's like okay well what is your
rewarded to do in the past
where's the cat go the opposite way yeah
so the the reverse role model is
something similar but you're you're
almost taking this into a lifestyle
perspective so the reverse role model is
if you live in a town or you grow up
somewhere and there's no one around you
like the sort of person that you want to
be like but there are tons of people
like the person you don't want to be
like you can say there's a way marker I
don't want his relationship with
gambling I don't want the way that Hema
handles his finances I don't want the
way that him and his wife communicate
with each other it's like okay there we
go Warren Buffett uh Mungus says uh like
an amazing amount of success has been
achieved by not trying to be smart but
avoiding being stupid uh so there's your
way markers there but what you're saying
is that this is almost like a a
abstracted lifestyle version of this
these are all of the things that I hate
to do what's the opposite of that yeah
and the
uh challenge of I don't know precisely
what the exact thing is therefore I
can't move toward it is one of mine
which is perfectionism is
procrastination masquerading as quality
control I was gonna say it's a it's a
fallacy it's a it's a decision-making
fallacy
it's the same it's this is why investor
frames can be so useful like if you're
looking for the perfect investment you
won't find one there's always downsides
every every investment has risk right
and so using that frame you're like well
there's all these paths which one do I
choose it's like well you have to the
one thing that's guaranteed is if you
keep the money it will go down in value
because it'll inflate right so not
investing is the only way guaranteed to
not get a retirement investment is that
a
the fact that inflation exists do you
think that's a useful motivating force
for business people you know you could
imagine a different form of world
economics where you know like embedded
growth obligations weren't there and
like whatever you know inflation didn't
happen do you think that that sort of
motivates people to actually be like oh
[__] like I need to I need to do
something with this money I can't just
sit sit and leave it in the bank I think
it would motivate investors yes more
yeah yeah but I mean the the business
people would just like probably keep
more coins in there in their vault and
just keep transacting is that Scrooge
McDuck yeah they'd be less likely to
they'd be less likely to deploy Capital
faster because if you feel like there's
a cost of capital that's higher for
keeping it like letting it sit there
then you have a higher urgency to do
something with it if you have less
urgency then you only do it when you
know it's gonna crash
you gain nothing from underestimating
your opponent mm-hmm
how does this relate to your
world
so a lot of the tweets that I have
actually come from conversations I have
with our portfolio CEOs and so they'll
say something right
um and they're like oh we're way better
than those guys
and I think somebody said like something
like that on a meeting and I just
thought about it and I was like what a
stupid thing to say
I was like you gained nothing from that
statement I was like you literally
gained like what do you gain from that
you gain complacency right you you
increase you increase the likelihood of
looking stupid in the case that they do
Crush you right I was like
because on the flip side like how many
UPS like the only things that upset the
guys who are on the top of the mountain
is hubris
like there's really no reason that the
guy on the top of the mountain should
ever lose he has the most resources he
has the most he has the highest
perspective he's the most Vision like he
is everything he's all the food at the
top of the mountain and yet history
shows us humans act like humans and so
we lose because of our egos and because
it hurts to say what if that person's
better than me
and so
I think that if you it actually is is
really uh parallel with a different uh
tweet that that kind of took off which
was
people underestimate how much smarter
you can see him if you have 20 minutes
of preparation yeah that's that's so
[__] true right and so like
believable
people get into businesses and like well
what if you actually had to face this
team people were like well I don't want
to practice it's like why not like why
wouldn't you practice like for a lot of
Fighters show up not having prep for the
fight not really hard I'm like what do
you gain from that because if you
practice really hard you get better
period and like all it is is purely an
ego play
the only the only win you get from not
prepping and showing up to the fight is
that you appear to be more naturally
gifted and I would rather be known for
my work ethics than my natural gift as
an aside but you appear to be more
naturally gifted and then you win by
less than you would if you prepared
you gain nothing and so it's purely an
ego thing but you we do it all the time
and so I wanted to like my my Twitter
stream is just thoughts to self I
deleted because I don't have enough room
in my profile to say but it was
originally like notes to self and it's
just like to remind me of things as they
come up because I fall into that trap
too I'm like I'm gonna we're gonna
outperform this guy or like this company
is going to crush it like but we don't
gain anything from that it's like so we
just have to assume that we're always
the underdog and then they've got to
trick up their sleeve that we don't know
about
it's like that's the whole uh only the
paranoid survive um
a reverse of that or something that's
interesting to do with people at the top
of the pyramid is there's only one way I
know to beat people who copy you get
bigger it's not by direct conflict but
by making them shrink into irrelevance
by comparison
agree I mean especially when it comes to
content creation I imagine that this is
something that oh yeah that you know you
see one thing that becomes effective and
then Downstream from that a lot of stuff
happened and you know if you've done the
hard work of forging ahead trailblazing
pathfinding split testing wow we finally
came up with this thing and then within
four weeks you're like oh brilliant this
is all over the internet now
well I always see it as like a first
mover thing which is like they need me I
don't need them they require me in order
to iterate their content I don't because
I don't look at Theirs to make mine and
so and it's because like everybody knows
man as well everybody knows every single
person that's copying thumbnails there's
copying subtitle subtitle Styles that's
you know going after the same talking
points they know deep down that what
they're doing is creating a rough-hoon
pixelated equivalent of what they think
they can try and be at at best what you
can hope for is being the second best
Alex homozy in the world right and I'll
win that game but like they would beat
me at being whoever they are correct I
mean this sounds so trite but like I I'm
trying to say this in a different way so
that it hits because like people have
heard like there's only one version of
you like there's just so much actual
meet to that concept because
this is this is you know Gary originally
did the document don't create thing and
I think that the the reason that the
content that we have is quote original
is because like we document I I document
through Twitter the things that come up
in my actual life and so it's not like
what's trending right now it's like well
I had this meeting with a CEO and he
[__] said that thing about the
competitor and that's my tweet and there
wasn't somebody else in the meeting also
going oh brilliant that's a lesson that
I can take that I can use for my Twitter
right and so it's all from like original
source and if everyone else like and
this is on the flip side if you're the
person who's doing this like you need to
find what your original sources of
content because like you will always be
second
or who SEC you'll never be first is
really the is really the statement and
like at least for me if I'm playing a
game I want to play for the Long Haul
and the point of the game is keep the
game going and if you want to keep the
game going then you can't be dependent
on someone else
there was another one I thought was
quite interesting especially given the
kind of current world of uh men's advice
and rich guy uh existence online
more people stay poor because of their
egos than get rich off them yeah at the
moment it seems like egos are being
valorized on the internet especially
among men's advice yeah how is it that
more people stay poor because of their
egos and get rich off them if there's a
bunch of examples of people with
seemingly big egos that also have money
I think that's um what's the fallacy
um
whatever the whatever the cognitive
follows you for what's in front of your
eyes
there you go
um I think there are far more people who
are successful and significantly more
successful than the people who are
visible on
content who and I would say many of
those people aren't actually that
successful and so if we're looking at
the objective measure of success as like
net worth just for just for the sake of
this conversation there are far more
people who are rich and Anonymous than
there are people who flaunt their
Lamborghinis that they rented for a day
now they're I mean if you really think
about the influencer world of business
there are not that many guys who
actually like are really in the game
like most of those guys sell something
from their platform about building a
platform like that's that's 90 not even
95 it's probably like 98 99 and so
there's only like a very small select
and and to be fair those guys
are all pretty humble like you look at
the Gary's you look at the the Andes you
look at the
um Tom Billy like these at my life like
you know like the guys who have become
you know in in the business space like
they're not particularly egotistical
guys and it's usually because they know
what heart feels like and they know what
it's like to be inadequate over and over
and over again because you only can be
inadequate if you go to another level if
you feel amazing it's because you
haven't moved up
does that mean that if somebody wants to
be successful and they feel like they've
still got an ego that they need to do
some work on dissolving that I think
they just need to do harder things
like you need to fight harder opponents
like because you're waiting in this
little pool the only way you can
maintain an ego is by believing that
you're a big fish in a little Pond right
it's a big fish in whatever size Pond do
you think it is and if you're a big fish
you're not in a big enough pond it's
totally delusion
it's hard to comprehend like Bezos if
you've heard any of his interviews seems
like a very humble guy but like you
could have a hundred billionaires in a
room and he is worth the same amount as
them
and then if you had each one of those
billionaires is a thousand millionaires
he's still worth the same the same
amount as one thousand one hundred
whatever a hundred thousand millionaires
ended him
so like there's just levels to it and I
think the moment you get the ego is the
moment you stop growing because you feel
like you beat the level but you just
keep repeating the love rather than
moving up because there is a harder boss
and they just haven't faced it yet
I suppose
it's an easy way you know if you were
going to a karate class uh but you
decided instead of going to the adult
one to go to the one that's Under 11's
yeah and you're gonna kick the [__] out
of all of these yeah and you video it
and you're like look at me and it just
happens to be that they're the same size
as you and like just imagine they're
like dumb on the inside but they're
human you know adult size and you're
kicking the [__] out of them it's like
yeah do it to Jones right like not gonna
happen yeah and so like
this yeah I'm just trying to say this
the way that I take this the way I mean
it I get comments from people who are
like love your humility Alex and like I
don't think I'm that humble of a guy
being real at least internally in my own
head but I am reminded daily of my
inadequacy on the business game because
like right now we've moved up a level in
terms of like now we're now we're doing
deals now we're investing in companies
we're taking on big risks we're writing
checks like the another level of the
game than just owning not to say that
owning one business and growing it is
not hard it absolutely is a different
kind of heart but like I'm getting into
this game and I'm absolutely the small
fish like Warren Buffett made 90 billion
dollars on the trading made in apple in
2020.
one move right and so I'm like I am
entering into a game like how could I
say that I'm good like even if I was
exceptional it's still going to take 20
years to prove it
so like I can't say anything and by that
point I'll probably have other guys who
are you know who are [__] Titans at
that point to remind me of the fact that
I'm not as good as them so
in your estimation is the presence of an
ego something which artificially limits
the size of the vision of how high you
want to climb yeah 100 and because it's
you cannot you can't both say that you
are you cannot admit death sits and say
you're awesome at the same time in my
opinion like I can't say like I suck at
all these things and then also be like
I'm the best you can't do it you either
like you suck at all these things and I
think it's the Dunning Kruger effect
which is like the more you the more you
learn about something the more the more
you realize you don't know and so I
think that if you have a tiny tiny
subset of things that you are studying
and a tiny subset of people you're
comparing yourself to then it it's
really easy to feel awesome about
yourself but if you compare yourself to
I mean I compare myself every day to
Warren Buffett and like he's my app him
and Monger like my heroes mostly because
the way they lived life and what they
like just everything about the way they
lived is something that I just love and
like I have Buffett's net worth by age
tracked and I have like mine tracked and
I'm like all right just gotta stay above
that line
at the moment I am right now but like I
had a you know like
his world was different yeah like I got
Warren didn't have Warren to learn from
yes very interesting it's um I mean you
took we spoke about this at the very
very start where you were saying you
have the opportunity of using the
blueprint that has been laid down by me
yeah so if you've got nothing to lose do
um do the me thing yeah you know you
have all of the mistakes all of the
failures and all of the successes and he
there was another one where you said the
rarer you are the rarer the people are
who share your perspective in this way
the greater your success the fewer
people you can share it with I was
playing with this quote from a land
about on from the school of life for
ages which was uh
loneliness is a kind of tax you have to
pay to atone for a certain complexity of
mind and I'm really not sure because
since I've been in Austin the complexity
of Mind thing which is that hasn't
stopped but the loneliness changed and I
figured that that was a big function of
change of environment and maybe like
whatever embracing or an acceptance of
of what was going on
but again is this a byproduct of success
that
a lot of people don't necessarily
realize it's a price that's going to be
need to be paid if you want to achieve a
ton of success you end up at this
rarified strata out in the troposphere
somewhere and you're like well you're
like
five people that I can talk to that
understand what I'm going through at the
moment or another question as well is
that a combination of hubris and
self-delusion like is that true or other
things that the bus driver or the lady
that serves you at Whole Foods can
actually like relate to you on
so two questions one is I would probably
reject the notion that it's a prize
overall because like
being in like if you think about it as a
mountain there's less there's less
square footage at the top of the
mountain just is there's fewer people
there and the air is thinner it's harder
to get there harder to breathe right and
you have to adjust it you have to
acclimate and the people that are around
you like there are fewer of them but you
can make the argument that they have
even more context than anyone else
possibly could so maybe the relationship
you have are potentially deeper even if
they're not
humans don't need that many
relationships so like you just have a
smaller pool to choose from but like
most people only have two or three good
relationships in their life anyways and
so like you just have a narrower pool
that you can make that selection from
and um I mean of the people that I have
interacted with who are far above that
above me on the mountain
um that's been there that's what they've
relayed to me
um
but it's only bad if you think it's a
cost
if you're okay with it because there are
plenty of people who are lonely right
now and don't have [__]
so and there's you know and you already
know this but like there's something
being lonely and Solitude you know
um and one is seen as bad the other
scene is fine or good so in some circles
that scene is self-care so
uh so to me it just means that like I
think your tolerance or your standard
for friends raises and
I'll share this and hopefully it comes
off the right way
I entered communities as I was coming up
and was like wow everyone here is bigger
than me and then I was able to through
achievement rise through that and then I
lost context with that group and so I
think there's just more free agency a
friendship that happens on your climb up
because you're just moving between
strata more frequently than it is that
if I settled at one of these levels then
I would eventually find all the people
at that rung but if you're constantly on
the move up the mountain then more of
that is in transitionary Period on the
on the climb and it's only a problem if
you'd hate it
I don't
what don't you hate you don't hate the
fact that sort of people come and go
that some of these relationships are
kind of transient yeah it just doesn't
bother me
because I think it's like a should
statement which is like one of my big
things it's like why should I why does
it have to be why must it doesn't must
anything it just is that way and that's
fine
talking about social media we mentioned
this earlier on what are your
predictions for the next
six months to a couple of years in terms
of what you think is going to be
big any focuses or any interesting
trends that you're noticing at the
moment
I will stay first off that I'm not a
social media expert by any stretch but
just you know I think AI is going to be
the main driving force behind the future
of social media and I don't know how
we're going to deal with it
um I mean there's already the Deep fakes
of Rogan doing entire podcasts with
Steve Jobs that are gone out there and
the entire thing is both created and
recorded with AI and so I think it'll be
really interesting because right now
it's still not as good as the best
creators but in a few machine
Generations it'll make the best content
every time in seconds and I'm not sure
what it's going to I think that I know
the verification check mark is going to
matter more it'll change in its meaning
right now I mean status in the future
it'll mean real person
um
so that I'll make that prediction that
the verification of Bot versus human
will become more important in the future
I can make that prediction
um and that there will be more AI
generated content in the future than
there is today
um and how we respond to it I don't know
it's scary to think that what we
basically had for the last
five years or so since the algorithm
started to get really tight is a
three-way feedback mechanism from
algorithms designing
better delivered content to users it
also nudges the user's preferences so
that they are easier and more
predictable to predict that was that
two-way street was something I learned
from Stuart Russell is [__] amazing
uh everybody needs to understand that
it's not just you programming the
algorithm it's the algorithm programming
you and it's one of the reasons that it
explains increasing Division and
extremity because if you are far right
or far left or super whatever or super
the other thing it makes you way easier
to predict and that's a byproduct of any
algorithmic optimizing function
and then the third element of that is
audience capture by the creators because
they are the third element of the
creation of the content right that they
go how well did that perform uh oh well
we will red meet that a little bit more
in a little bit more in a little bit
more and then you end up on your knees
like cooking for the audience right
the fourth element of this is going to
be then you are able to algorithmically
create content that understands the back
end of the algorithm that can nudge
preferences and can get feedback and all
of that I mean that to me is
[__] me if we think that you know like
the degree of over bearingness that
social has on our lives at the moment
like that's a very very big deal we'll
cut out the middle man
the Creator being the middleman and then
just becomes a vertically integrated
platform that creates content on its own
using Ai and just feeds it directly to
the audience that's why as soon as those
uh the AI images of hot girls came out
and then chat GPT you go look like only
fans you're no longer an agency you're
now a tech company that should be the
move that you make every single person
should have their own curated wifey
girlfriend online and that's that's what
you that's your thing like and it would
be infinitely scalable you know like the
perfect Dirty Talk completely curated
and twiddled to your specific whatever
it is uh but
that doesn't bode particularly well for
how much limbic hijack and freedom
people have from social media because it
is only going to become more and more
compelling which isn't necessarily a
good thing I mean I
good bad no idea
um I I think there will probably be a
little bit of a counter movement
um of people who want to do more things
in person make social media human again
all right well you know an interesting
thought experiment that I had I was like
because we've we've taken some things
and I I do think AI is going to happen
but like I said it will continue
um but I was like
we accept all technology as inevitable
and I was thinking about this and I was
like has there ever been a technology
that humans have created that we were
like nah we shouldn't do this I thought
about it I was like there is one nuclear
bombs we all were like
I think it's better if we don't we
should just not do this and everyone
just like agreed we're like we're not
going to do this and I I think the the
rate of AI how disaggregated it is like
will prevent that from happening but I
just thought about that as like it just
there hasn't been any other
technological thing that I've seen
besides nuclear bombs that we all
together were like this isn't good for
us have you seen how tabletop genetic
sequencing machines work no this is a
really good example of what you're
talking about so the way that pretty
much all of them are cloud based and in
order to sequence whatever it is that
you're looking to sequence it sends the
the request up to the cloud and there's
three gradings there's green Amber and
red and if it's green you can just do it
no one checks if there's Amber you have
to submit a proposal for what it is
where it's going BSL level Etc security
security if it's right you just can't do
it and then presumably someone comes
around and goes excuse me what the [__]
are you doing trying to make smallpox
yeah um but that there's been I think
it's
either two or three times in the history
of Gene sequencing there has been a
moratorium placed globally on this
everyone's gone every [__] machine
goes off everything stop until we work
out what's going on so there are
situations that's a great example like
cloning as you just said
as soon as you start to atomize that and
disaggregate it and distribute it
between enough different actors how are
you going to be able to control you know
and the the other thing is with genetic
sequencing the the kind of machines that
you need the hardware is complex yeah
it's expensive and it's rare yeah the
hardware is not complex for anybody can
code and the reward is everything it's
the world it's the world it's it's
domination it's money it's success it's
all of those things this is why I don't
know man like the [__] the Techno
Optimist thing ever since I read super
intelligence by Nick boss from five or
six years ago I just don't see an AGI
future where stuff doesn't get [__] uh
I don't know would whether we get the
general bit of AGI super AGI is like
still up for a big part of debate but if
you end up creating this very strange
World in which everyone's limically
hijacked with their own personal news
feed of like perfectly remember
Cambridge analytica and the um those
scandals around the Hillary Clinton ads
it's like I know you're prep references
and we're going to create these
perfectly done ads so okay I mean the
ads are still created by a human and it
was still you were bucketed into a
content with other men of this age with
these interests in this area with these
voting habits
imagine if every single news feed not
just post news feed was perfectly
curated to maximize time says hey Chris
like that's the first line of every ad
yeah crazy yeah but it might just be the
same as email the first time there was
personalized email all of a sudden you
stop becoming responsive to your own
name
um
so like I think though I think they'll
be push-pull
um on that stuff but uh I'm with you on
the AGI long term you know as a weird
thought experiment if you think about
what God looks like in terms of most
most definitions they're like an
omniscient omnipotent being and I think
we're just creating that like what does
AI know it knows everything
right what can it do everything
immediately
like weird
usually God would be benevolent yes
rolling the benevolence in there yeah
might be good if we could it's long
God's long-term benevolent
uh but short term sometimes mean yeah
you are true it's definitely wrath yeah
in almost all things what are you
working on now what can people expect
from you next uh 100 leads 100 million
dollar leads uh which is the second book
in the 100 million dollar series
um is going to come out
this year so that's exciting uh we will
we will be done the the edited final
draft uh within seven days so I'm like
it's been uh we put in 3 500 hours
um together my editor and I
um combined over the last two years
doing it so it is the first four to six
hours of my day every day like before I
came here I was editing the book and
that's what I did yesterday and that's
what I did before
um
so that it could be really really good
and so that's that's the that's the big
creative side of me is the is the book
it'll be 99 Cents there you go I get 33
of that by the way
um yes yes we're having a rich
um and then the rest of uh my life is
all about deals it's just uh we've got
some really interesting companies that
we're investing in
um very very pumped on that side
um so yeah if you've got a one to ten
million dollar ebitda business uh and
you would like a growth partner go to
acquisition.com and let us know I really
appreciate you I really really enjoyed
this today it's been cool to come and
see so thank you for having me
appreciate it hopefully the audience got
what they wanted
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face
foreign